it was the 5th birthday of Gabriela
Akari Ratliff earlier this week that
prompted her mother and now her father
to begin their hunger strikes and this
was the moment the family friends and
supporters facetimed Gabriela who's
living with her grandparents in Iran was
illegally she's entitled to
unconditional release which is why she
goes along because obviously if she was
feeling optimistic she wouldn't have won
on hunger strike if I was feeling
optimistic I wouldn't be joining her and
so yeah there there's always the
potential for something good to happen
but it hasn't yet a meeting with the
foreign secretary this morning was
encouraging Jeremy Hunt calling on the
Iranian regime to do the right thing and
show the world their humanity this is an
incredibly brave family their daughter
was five years old last week
Nazneen has been in prison for more than
half her daughter's life and we are
thinking of them and our message to Iran
is whatever the disagreements you may
have with the United Kingdom there is an
innocent woman at the heart of this she
just wants to get back together with her
daughter Gabriela to reunite that family
please show that you have humanity show
that you have a heart
let Nazanin come home and all the while
volunteers work knitting what they call
the chain of care with a link for every
day
Nazneen has been in jail for supposedly
being a member of an illegal
organization mr. Gary Ratcliffe has
admitted he would not have advised his
wife to begin a hunger strike
now given the simmering tensions between
the West and the Iranian regime in
Tehran but he's vowing to continue his
hunger strike here for as long as his
wife continues hers in Iran
the plan is for mr. su career active to
camp on the pavement outside the embassy
for as long as it takes to win his
wife's freedom Phil Edwards Sky News
central London